have you seen the clip of rand paul
taking fauchi to task for his part in
the funding of gain of research
of gain of gain of function research uh
is a word missing here
and the role of the nih why is fauci
still on the coveted team with such
clear conflicts of interest
and given that china are i guess is a
two-part question
um given that china are anti-us
anti-black have no qualms genociding
their own people and they dabble in
genetic hybrids shouldn't the null
hypothesis be that covet is a bio weapon
that cut out before it was ready maybe
that's really two different questions
um i actually haven't seen the clip i
know you have of rand paul taking
faoshita task
yep something to say about it yeah i
mean it's a
fascinating clip rand paul is a doctor
so he's well positioned to do this he
didn't have to be but he was
and fauci is clearly
possessing of some little glossary that
has not been distributed to anybody that
explains why the words he's using don't
have the meaning that they would
obviously seem to have if any normal
person said them
so anyway yeah it's it's what your
definition of is is it's yeah it depends
well yeah it is exactly that
um but yeah it's it's fascinating why
we're still listening to fouchy i have
no idea i have no idea and i think the
thing is
the allergy to trump was so severe
that anything that was viewed as in
opposition to trump has been
granted a kind of license
like no normal human being has and i
don't know how many times
i mean look i thought about digging it
up for today's live stream
but the clip of fouchy a few weeks ago
or a month ago
uh spinning tall tales about how
this virus may have come to humans
through an intermediate that we haven't
yet
found i mean it was more fouchy nonsense
as was
his but that's i mean that's that's
that's not new that's the standard
this has been on the table forever no no
but he recently
went about hypothesizing some new way it
could have happened that would explain
why we haven't found any evidence for it
it was just completely
out of thin air no evidence whatsoever
don't look over there look over here
you know never mind the man behind the
curtain stuff and
so the point is how many times would
fauci have to show up
lying or uh
just simply involved in a pathway that
is implicated in some i mean
he's central to the question of why gain
of function research was being
yeah funded during the trump
administration he lied to us about masks
and which we now know because he told us
that that's what he was doing
yeah um yeah i don't know why we're
still listening to him i find it
shocking
yeah and um maybe we don't want to
spend much time here but to the question
about whether or not the null hypothesis
the null hypothesis should be the code
is a bioweapon um
i don't think there's i hear what you're
saying
about what um you know that china can be
described as anti-us
and i don't know if it can be described
as anti-black but
it's engaged in genocide against some of
its own people um
and they do have capacity um i don't
think that's sufficient to make bio up
in a null hypothesis i think that that
would that would be
um cheating the same way frankly that
the standard issue virologists have been
cheating
by um trying to subvert the lab leak
hypothesis this whole time
no it's unparsimonious and you can
actually see it in the way you've had to
phrase the question because in order for
it to be a bio weapon
created by the chinese there has to have
been an accident
that got it released in a place that
would implicate the chinese
right so you wouldn't release it in
wuhan
if this was a bio weapon that wasn't
ready to go so you have to hypothesize a
lab leak
on top of a nefarious purpose no i mean
no you don't it could be a nefarious
purpose that specifically wanted to
implicate
the wave um okay but that's not what the
question sure but what we're doing here
is
exactly to your point that it's it it
requires a bunch of
epicycles right like it require it
requires a whole bunch of extra
levels of explanation which by
definition are not the most parsimonious
possibility
and the null should be the most
parsimonious possibility um
you know should given what you lay out
here should this be on the table of
possibility should it be among the list
of possible hypotheses yeah
it should be yeah but if you're going to
have that list and i did make an attempt
to
in my flow chart from all those months
ago i did attempt to be exhaustive there
were lots of very low probability things
on it
um but you would have to include not
just a
chinese bio weapon but you'd have to
include the possibility that somebody
else
released it intentionally and they did
so in wuhan in order to implicate the
chinese because
people would inevitably check those dots
anyway i'm not saying any of those
things are
likely um we haven't seen evidence for
any of them so let's leave them all
as possibilities that must formally be
included in a complete solution set but
for which there is no evidence
[Music]